and you have this fundamental vision of
optimism you call yourself an optimist I
mean in this world I have a sort of I
see myself a little bit as the main
character from the idiot by Dostoevsky
who was also kind of seen by society as
a fool because he was optimistic so one
can you maybe articulate where that
sense of optimism comes from and maybe
also try to articulate your vision of
the future where people are inspired or
optimism drives us yes it's easy to
forget that when you look at social
media and so on with the word toxicity
and negativity can often get more likes
that optimism has a sort of a beauty to
it and I I do hope it's out there so
what can you try to articulate vision
yeah so I mean for me optimism and being
an optimist is just seeing the silver
lining in every cloud you know even in
tragedy it brings people together and
the question is can we see that can you
see can you see the beauty that is in
everything
I don't think optimism is foolishness
I don't think optimism is blindness
though it probably involves some naivete
the belief that things will get better
the belief that that we tend towards the
good even in times of struggle or bad
you know you can't sustain war but you
can sustain peace you know I think I
think things that are stable are more
sustainable things that are optimistic
and more sustainable than things that
are you know chaotic cp+ fundamentally
good I mean some people may disagree
that you can't stress you can sustain
peace you can't sustain war I mean you
don't have to you I think war is costly
you know it involves life and money and
peace does not involve those things it
requires work I'm not saying it doesn't
require work but it it doesn't drain
resources I think the same way that war
does you know the people that would say
that we will always have war and I just
talked to the story in a Stalin is you
know would say the conflict and
desire for power and conflict is central
to human nature is sucker but something
in your words also perhaps it's the
naive aspect that I also share is that
you have an optimism that people are
fundamentally good and I'm an idealist
you know and I think idealism is good
I'm not I'm not a fool to believe that
the ideals that I imagined can come true
of course they'll never be world peace
but shouldn't we die trying you know I
think that's the whole point that's the
point of vision vision should be
idealistic and it should be all all
practical purposes impossible but that
doesn't mean we shouldn't try and it's
the it's the milestones that we we reach
that take us closer to that ideal that
make us feel that our life and our work
have meaning and we're contributing to
something bigger than ourselves you know
we just because it's impossible doesn't
mean we shouldn't try as I said we're
still moving the ball down the field
we're still making progress things are
still getting better even if we never
get to that that ideal State so I think
idealism is a is a good thing
you